[Music]
in his first public remark since the
release of a controversial audio
recording Donald Trump lashed out those
investigating him for allegedly removing
classified documents from the White
House this stuff doesn't hold up and
people know it this is the continuation
of the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
that's all it is
and its primary purpose is election
interference and we're not going to let
this
election be stolen from us but
the president made the remarks while
campaigning in New Hampshire on Tuesday
in the new audio recorded during a 2021
interview at his New Jersey Golf Course
Trump appears to show classified
material to AIDS and a writer working on
a memoir of a pentagon planned for a U.S
attack against Iran presented to him by
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff Mark milley when Trump was
president with Millie let me see that
I'll show you an example he said
that I wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
secret this is secret information
the U.S justice departments charged
Trump with 37 counts of mishandling top
secret documents the audio seems to
counter Trump's claim dozens of boxes
found last year at his Mar-A-Lago estate
were just newspaper clippings
prosecutors say many of those documents
were instead highly classified the
recording may also prove the
government's case that Trump did not
declassify the material as he should
have well in office
this was done by the military given to
me
we have a problem former president Trump
is currently awaiting trial he's pleaded
not guilty to the charges his trial is
set for August but prosecutors are
pushing to have that date moved to the
end of the year
Kimberly halket Al Jazeera Washington